cette image là voulez vous voyez a
certainement chez vous si vous avez des
enfants un enfant avec une tablette avec
un téléphone avec la télévision
l'ordinateur la gestion des écrans c'est
devenu tout un sport en tant que parent
dans les écoles aussi les enseignants
qui auront de la difficulté avec les
téléphones parfois un peu trop est
présent le ministre délégué à la santé
et aux services sociaux lyonnais
carrément est avec moi ce matin parce
qu'il va présider le forum sur la
dépendance aux écrans chez les jeunes
bonjour monsieur germain
bonjour alors si demain c'est la
première fois qu'on compte y est ça un
forum sur la dépendance des écrans ou
absolument ce qu'on veut c'est vraiment
être capable de définir qu'est ce que
c'est on sait que chez les enfants de
moins de cinq ans on a des guides des
guides de pratique sont claires mais à
partir de 2 ans et surtout jusque les
plus les plus grands vins jeunes on veut
savoir exactement quelles sont les
limites
qu'est ce qui est de la dépendance
qu'est ce qui est de l'utilisation
appropriée des écrans qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète à ce point de vouloir lancer
comme ça des consultations avec les
scientifiques mais je crois que la
population générale est inquiète le
monde a été donnée par le premier
ministre suite au congrès de notes de
notre relève et je pense que toute la
population est inquiète nous ce qu'on
veut savoir c'est vraiment quand est-ce
que l'utilisation des écrans devient un
problème de problèmes de santé physique
de santé psychologique quand est-ce
qu'il faut consulter et surtout quand
est ce qu'on a besoin de traitements à
quel point c'est trop exactement cette
question là en tant que parent je pense
qu'on se la posent à tous les jours
quand on veut gérer le nombre d'arh
toujours un combat avec avec nos enfants
le savoir on la met où la limite c'est
ça que vous voulez établir c'est ça quel
est le bon équilibre qu'on doit avoir
parce qu'il ya l'association des
médecins psychiatres du québec qui ont
lancé un cri d'alarmé dernièrement en
faisant l'association entre la santé
mentale des jeunes et possiblement la
surconsommation d'écran ce que vous
joignez votre voix à leurs inquiétudes à
ce sujet là je crois qu'on est tous
inquiets et surtout par exemple au
niveau de la maison des médecins
psychiatres
on parlait beaucoup du des réseaux
sociaux et de lacs et de l'anxiété mais
il faut savoir aussi c'est que les
écrans sont utilisés pour des fins
éducatives
est-ce que ça rentre dans le temps de
lisa sion d'écran est ce que quand on
lit notre journal sur une tablette est
ce que ça rentre dans le temps
d'utilisation écran donc c'est tout
c'est tout c'est foule qu'on veut mettre
en lumière avec les experts pour avoir
des balises claires dans vos données
sans en deux temps votre forum demain
c'est une journée consacrée aux experts
il ya eu des milliers d'étudiants qui se
sont penchés sur l'utilisation des
écrans chez les jeunes la dépendance
aussi vous voulez essayer de voir qu'est
ce qu'il ressent principalement le cesi
dessus de l'admettre c'est ça oui on
veut savoir un que les experts puissent
se parler entre eux parce que chacun a
une certaine position
on veut que puisse se parler entre eux
on veut leur poser des questions
également pour justement comme je vous
dis définir clairement qu est-ce que
c'est la limite et par la suite on va
donner la chance aux groupes
communautaires aux familles aux
éducateurs aussi c'est sa deuxième temps
le 20 mars prochain
exactement et comment ça va fonctionner
cette journée là alors on va faire plus
des ateliers
demain c'est vraiment en grands groupes
60 experts ensemble avec quelques
invités et ensuite la prochaine fois
être en grand en ateliers sur des sujets
bien spécifiques
vous en avez mentionné quelques uns est
ce qu'on doit utiliser ce qu'on a
utilisé le téléphone est ce qu'on peut
emmener le téléphone elle l école santé
soit vous moi je crois que pour le
moment on a pas d'évidence assez clair
pour le pour l'interdire mais peut-être
que c'est une bonne chose de ne pas
permettre quand est ce qu'on a besoin
d'aller chercher des traitements par
exemple est-ce que c'est sur le nombre
d'heures d'exposition ou est ce que
c'est vraiment quand on est des
symptômes de dépendance
on veut plus aller à l'école en veut
plus dormir on veut plus manger est-ce
que c'est là la limite
est-ce que vous avez des réserves aussi
concernant les les cours de sport
électronique qui est que son nez dans
les écoles dans certaines écoles au
québec cette année
ok ça fait depuis 2010 est en fait de
concours
skanska comment expliquer ce que c'est
vraiment des enfants qui déjà en une
consommation excessive d'écran est ce
qu'on essaie de leur donner c'est un
nouvel équilibre donc pour chaque heure
de
d'écran il ya une heure d'activité
physique même dans les écoles ceux qui
sont le plus exposées à l'activité
physique
ils sont bien encadrés par leur part
leur enseignant est également il ya une
chaire de recherche qui a été créé pour
suivre l'évolution de ces enfants là et
leur et leur parcours
donc c'est sûr que c'est un sujet qui
est dingue qui va être d'intérêt on va
en parler demain et il va falloir voir
avec le 20 mars à voir le le point de
vue de 10 de ses anciennes élèves de ces
écoles sur l'utilisation de ce
curriculum en terminant mais c'est
clairement est ce qu'il ya un plan
d'action qui va découler de tout ça
oui le premier ministre m'a demandé un
plan d'action entre le à partir de
demain on va travailler sur un document
de travail et qu'on va exposer le 20
mars et par la suite on va avoir un plan
d'action sur le diagnostic le traitement
et les la sensibilisation aussi ça va
être certainement très très suivi tout
ça vous touche est vraiment un sujet
très important pour bon nombre de
familles bon nombre d'écoles aussi
lionel carmant merci beaucoup il me
laissait d'une voix merci aussi au vent
et justement lien avec ce forum
notre collègue allaient label propose ce
matin sur notre site web
l'ong arctique qui porte justement sur
la surexposition les enfants aux écrans
ce qu'on doit vraiment s'inquiéter
en tant que parent il ya presque 12
mille études qui ont été réalisées sur
le sujet depuis les années 70 mais
l'arrivée des tablettes et des
téléphones et des gens ont changé la
donne donc un texte à lire on vous le
propose sur le site web de radio-canada